before we get into today's episode I
wanted to let you know that we're going
to be taking a short break from
uploading videos for the next couple of
weeks but we will be back soon with
brand new episodes and you won't even
have to miss us the entire time because
some of the microcosmos team will be
doing a live stream here on the channel
during the break and you can find more
information about that on the community
tab here on YouTube or on our Twitter at
journey to micro
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
our master of microscopes was cleaning
the Marine tanks that some of his
organisms live in when he noticed this
creature
it was hard to miss given that it was
visible to the naked eye thanks to both
its bright red color and large size what
he had found was a species of
foraminifera which are single-celled
amoeboid creatures that spend their
lives poking their false feet or
pseudopodia through holes in their tests
which is what we call their shells but
foraminifera are perhaps best known for
what they reveal to us in death their
tests are preserved as fossils that
record our planet's history in their own
chemical composition and among the
various things that make foraminifera so
helpful is one very simple fact
foraminifera fossils are large
for comparison here is a one Euro coin
sitting next to an array of formula for
a fossils the four M's are not large the
way a T-Rex is large but they are still
big enough to substitute for an object
that people use every day when you zoom
in to our giant red foreign you can see
the contents of its cytoplasm streaming
in both directions we think that this
particular forum is a member of a group
called The xenophyophores which are deep
sea organisms that have tiny crystals in
their cytoplasm called granelli that are
usually made from barium sulfite
absorbed like a glittery souvenir from
the places the forehand once lived
usually when we look at slides under the
microscope we're on the hunt for
creatures that are smaller than a speck
of dust creatures For Whom the whole
microscopy slide is a vast World they
may never see the entirety of but this
foraminifera is large yes we are aware
that we have said that multiple times in
this video but it's really worth
emphasizing the cover slip that James
used in this footage was about 22
millimeters in length on each side and
Our Mysterious red giant managed to
extend its web of pseudopodia across
practically the entire surface and yet
we do not want you to think that all
foreign are like this over 500 million
years there have been tens of thousands
of 4am species both extinct and still
surviving that we know of there are some
far less than a millimeter in diameter
While others are centimeters in diameter
the larger of these foraminifera are
known by an extremely technical name of
larger foraminifera it's an name that
hints at a question we've sometimes
wondered during our journey through the
microcosmos if life works so well at
such tiny scales why bother with size
what is the point of being large
of course this question is too big for
any single organism to answer but
scientists have spent a considerable
amount of time studying foraminifera
which has yes led to the publication of
papers with relatable titles like why
are a larger foraminifera large
larger foraminifera are typically found
in warm Waters where conditions are
stable but food is usually scarce that
might sound surprising it seems like if
you're living in an area without much
food it would be difficult to grow so
large but one of the reasons these
particular form and nephera are able to
grow so large is because they have help
within their tests are chambers that
house algal symbians like the foramina
for his own personal Greenhouse that
they can Harvest photosynthetic products
from these symbionts compensate for the
lack of nutrition in the foraminiferous
environment and yet symbiosis alone is
not enough to explain the larger
forminifera's size there are smaller
species with algae symbiance and larger
species without them so while the
symbians help the organisms survive in
these nutrient poor areas and it
certainly doesn't hurt to have the size
and test complexity to house them they
aren't the main main factor that decides
that a forum species will become larger
what ultimately drives that shift is the
choice foreign make on when to reproduce
in an environment where food is
plentiful forearms will reproduce at an
earlier age but reproducing earlier
means smaller baby forums that are
vulnerable to Predators or currents that
take them to less ideal environments so
these smaller foraminifera are playing a
numbers game their survival as a species
is contingent on proliferating enough
that these threats to the individual
forearms can't take them all out but
larger foraminifera aren't living in
those kinds of places they Brave more
restricted conditions ones where it
makes more sense for them to wait a
little longer to reproduce so they can
focus their resources and energy on
producing offspring that will be more
likely to survive than a large
population of tiny foraminifera these
larger forums spend years expanding
their single-celled bodies so that by
the time they reproduce their offspring
will be larger and hardier compared to
their smaller counterparts their
survival as a species is driven by the
survival of these individual young and
over millions of generations this
strategy means the evolution of larger
species
these adaptations have made the large
foramina for a very specialized in terms
of the kind of conditions they thrive in
and that's great for survival in the
moment but it creates problems for them
in the very very very long term in the
hundreds of millions of years that
foraminifer have been around mass
extinctions have wiped out countless
species including it turns out larger
foraminifera again and again their
adaptation to such a narrow specialized
environment has rendered them unable to
contend with the changes around them
fast enough and on the flip side of that
Extinction coin they're smaller more
rapidly reproducing counterparts have
had the numbers and adaptability to
survive they may not be as well adapted
to the same Niche that larger
foraminifera are but what good is being
well adapted to a niche when that Niche
is changing
through the fossil record left behind by
foraminifera we can see this history
play out over and over again the fossils
show mass extinctions have obliterated
larger foraminifera but the fact that it
happens again and again also reveals
something else the larger form anaphora
may find themselves knocked down with
each Extinction but well they get back
up again it seems like evolution is
never going to keep them down because
that's what happens Evolution life
rebounds and when it does the larger
foraminifera evolve once again in the
same kinds of conditions we see them
living in today over and over again this
form appears almost as if the larger for
manifera is inevitable but of course
nothing is inevitable life has gone
through so many extinctions and much of
what has emerged on the other side is
very different from what came before we
live with the shadows of dinosaurs
source and giant mammals and maybe the
future could someday hold some Shadow
form of us
and in that future foreign fossils will
record the World As We lift it a world
that the larger for a manifera probably
did not survive but that it will still
have managed to return to eventually
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us we wanted to let you
know that we still have Journey to the
microcosmos calendars available in stock
at complexlycalendars.com each
spectacular image is accompanied by a
little blurb explaining what you're
looking at and each photo showcases both
James's work as an artist and of course
the beauty of the microcosmos so if you
love this little world that we almost
never get to see how about stick it on
your wall for all of 2023 you're going
to need a wall calendar so why not get
one that helps to support your favorite
microscopic YouTube channel you can find
it at complexitycalendars.com where some
of the other shows from complexly the
company that produces this show also
have calendars available and you can
find all of them at the link in the
description
the people whose names are on the screen
right now they are our patrons on
patreon thank you so much to all of you
for supporting what we do so that we can
continue to explore all of the weird and
wonderful ways that life on this planet
functions we couldn't do it without that
support and so we're very grateful and
so are all the other people who enjoy
what we do here if you would like to
join these people you can do that at
patreon.com journey to micro if you want
to see more from our master of
microscopes James Weiss you can check
out jam and germs on Instagram and if
you want to see more from us there's
probably a subscribe button somewhere
nearby
foreign
[Music]